algorithms are everywhere they sort and
separate the winners from the losers the
winners get the job or a good credit
card offer the losers don't even get an
interview or they pay more for insurance
we're being scored with secret formulas
that we don't understand that that often
don't have systems of Appeal that begs
the question what if the algorithms are
wrong to build an algorithm you need two
things you need data what happened in
the past and a definition of success the
thing you're looking for and often
hoping for you train an algorithm by
looking figuring out for the algorithm
figures out what is associated with
success what situation leads to success
actually everyone uses algorithms they
just don't formalize them and written
code let me give you an example I use an
algorithm every day to make a meal for
my family the data I use is the
ingredients in my kitchen the time I
have the ambition I have and I'd curate
that data I don't count those little
packages of ramen noodles as food my
definition of success is a meal is
successful if my kids eat vegetables
it's very different from if my youngest
son were in charge he'd say successes if
he could see lots of Nutella but I get
to choose success I am in charge my
opinion matters that's the first rule of
algorithms algorithms are opinions
embedded in code it's really different
from what you think most people think of
algorithms they need algorithms they
think algorithms are objective and true
and scientific that's a marketing trick
it's also a marketing trick to
intimidate you with algorithms to make
you trust and fear math at
algorithms because you trust and fear
mathematics a lot can go wrong when we
put blind faith in big data this is key
resource she's a high school principal
in Brooklyn in 2011 she told me her
teachers were being scored with a
complex secret algorithm called the
value-added model I told her well figure
out what the formula to show it to me
I'm going to explain it to you she said
well I tried to get the formula but my
Department of Education contact told me
it was math and I wouldn't understand it
gets worse the New York Post filed a
Freedom of Information Act request that
all the teachers names and all their
scores and they published them as an act
of teacher shaming when I tried to get
the formulas a source code through the
same means I was told I couldn't I was
denied I later found out that nobody in
New York City had access to that formula
no one understood it then someone really
smart got involved Gary Rubinstein he
found 665 teachers for that New York
Post data that actually had two scores
that could happen if they were they were
teaching seventh grade math and eighth
grade math he decided to plot them each
dot represents a teacher
what is that that should never have been
used for enjoyed individual assessments
it's almost a random number generator
but it was this is Sara wasabi she got
fired
along with 205 other teachers for the
Washington DC school district even
though she had great recommendations
from her principal and the parents of
her kids I know what a lot of you guys
are thinking especially the data
scientists the a is for Tara you're
thinking well I would never make an
algorithm that that inconsistent but
algorithms can go wrong even have deeply
destructive effects with good intentions
and where is an airplane that's designed
badly crashes to the earth and everyone
sees it an algorithm designed badly can
go on for a long time silently wreaking
havoc this is roger ailes
he founded foxnews in 1996 more than 20
women complained about sexual harassment
they said they weren't allowed to
succeed at Fox News he was ousted last
year but we've seen recently that the
problems have persisted that begs the
question what should Fox News do to turn
over another leaf well what if they
replaced their hiring process with a
machine learning algorithm that sounds
good right think about it the data
what would the database a reasonable
choice would be the last 21 years of
applications to Fox News reasonable what
about the definition of success
reasonable choice would be well who's
successful at Fox News I guess someone
who say stayed there for four years and
was promoted at least once sounds
reasonable
and then the algorithm would be trained
it would be trained to look for people
to learn what led to success what kind
of applications led to historically led
to success by that definition now think
about what that what would happen if we
apply that to the current pool of
applicants it would filter out women
because they do not look like people who
are successful
in the past algorithms don't make things
fair if you just lively blindly apply
algorithms they don't make things fair
they repeat our past practices our
patterns they automate the status quo
that would be great if we had a perfect
world but we don't and I'll add that
most companies don't have embarrassing
lawsuits what the data scientists in
those companies are told to follow the
data to focus on accuracy think about
what that means
because we all have bias it means they
could be codifying sexism or any other
kind of bigotry thought experiment so I
like them an entirely segregated Society
racially segregated all towns all
neighborhoods and where we send the
police only to the minority
neighborhoods to look for crime the
arrest data would be very biased what if
on top of that we we founded it a
scientist and pay the data scientist to
predict where the next crime would occur
minority neighborhood Oh or to predict
who the next criminal would be a
minority they would the outdated science
will to brag about how great and how
accurate their model would be and they'd
be right now reality isn't that drastic
but we do have severe segregation and
many cities and towns that we have
plenty of evidence of bias policing and
justice system data and we actually do
predict hot spots places where crimes
will occur and we do predict in fact the
individual chrome criminality the
criminality of individuals the news
organization ProPublica recently looked
into one of those recidivism risk
algorithms as they're called being used
in Florida during sentencing by judges
Barnard on the Left the black man was
scored a ten out of ten Dillon on the
right three out of ten ten out of ten
high-risk
three out of ten low-risk
they were both brought in for drug
possession they both had records but
Dylan had a felony but Bernard didn't
this matters because the higher score
you are the more likely you're being
given a longer sentence what's going on
data laundering it's a process by which
technologists hide ugly truths inside
black box algorithms and call them
objective call the meritocratic when
their secret important and destructive
I've coined a term for these algorithms
weapons of mass destruction they're
everywhere and it's not a mistake these
are private companies building private
algorithms for private ends even the
ones I talked about for teachers and the
public police those are built by private
companies and sold to the government
institutions they call it their secret
sauce that's why they can't tell us
about it it's also private power they
are profiting from wielding the
authority of the inscrutable now you
might think since it's all this stuff is
private this competition may be the free
market will solve this problem
it won't there's a lot of money to be
made in unfairness also we're not
economic rational agents we all are
biased we're all racist and bigoted in
ways that we wish we weren't in ways
that we don't even know we know this
though they're in aggregate because
sociologists have consistently
demonstrated this with these experiments
they build where they send a bunch of
applications to jobs out equally qualify
but somehow by sending names and somehow
black sunny names are they all it's
always disappointing the result oh it so
we are the ones that are biased and we
are injecting those biases into the
algorithms by choosing what data to
collect like I chose not to think about
ramen noodles I decided was irrelevant
but by having the data trust
the data that's actually picking up on
past practices and by choosing the
definition of success how do we expect
the algorithms to emerge unscathed we
can't we have to check them we have to
check them for fairness the good news is
we can check them for fairness
algorithms can be interrogated and they
will tell us the truth every time and we
can fix them it can make them better I
call this an algorithmic audit it will
walk you through it first data integrity
check for the recidivism risk algorithm
I talked about a data integrity check
would mean we'd have to come to terms
with the fact that in the u.s. whites
and blacks smoked pot of the same rate
but blacks are far more likely to be
arrested four or five times more likely
depending on the area what is that bias
looking like in other crime categories
and how do we account for it second we
should think about the definition of
success audit that remember with the
hiring algorithm we talked about it
someone who stays for four years and is
promoted once well that is a successful
employee but it's also an employee that
is supported by their culture that's it
also it can be quite biased we need to
separate those two things we should look
to the blind orchestra audition as an
example that's where the people
auditioning are behind a sheet what what
I want to think about there is the
people who are listening have decided
what's important and they decided what's
not important and they're not getting
distracted by that
when the blind Orchestra auditions
started the number of women and
orchestras with up by a factor of five
next we have to consider accuracy this
is where the value-added model for
teachers would fail immediately no
algorithm is perfect of course so we
have to consider the errors of every
algorithm how often are there errors and
for whom does this model fail what is
the cost of that failure and finally we
have to consider the long-term effects
of algorithm the feedback loops that are
in generate and that sounds abstract but
imagine a facebook engineer to consider
that
before they decided to show us only
things that our friends had posted I
have two more messages one for the data
scientists out there data scientists we
should not be the arbiters of truth we
should be translators of ethical
discussions that happen in larger
society and the rest of you the non data
scientists this is not a math test is
the political fight we need to demand
accountability for our algorithmic
overlords the era of big data of blind
faith in big data must end thank you
very much
[Applause]